it's michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd cosmetic chemist
and paula's choice tragic i first got
into skincare around 2009 and back then
we didn't have all the brands we have
now not to mention all the skin cancer
we have now and paula bagoon was pretty
much the only person talking about the
science behind skincare and busting
skincare myths paula's choice and
everything else paul has done is
actually a really big reason why
science-based skincare is such a thing
now so i was a bit senpai noticed me
when paula's choice approached me to do
a sponsored video
now i know paul is very busy and
probably had nothing to do with it but
we don't know for sure so we're going to
assume that paula specifically picked me
like and subscribe to paula's favorite
youtuber and no one can prove that's not
true so it turns out i've never done a
video where i just talked about my
favorite paula's choice products so
that's what we're doing today paula's
choice have a lot of products i feel
like i've barely touched the range so
let me know your favorite products in
the comments so i can try out more of
them this is one of the few brands where
i really think that any skin type could
get their entire skincare routine from
their range they have 11 regular
cleansers and 20 moisturizers without
spf that is a lot so out of the products
that i have tried which is a fraction of
everything these are my favorites we're
going to start with the 2 bha liquid if
you followed me for a while you would
know that this would be in there this is
the first product from paula's choice
that i got when i first got into
skincare in 2009 it was my first i guess
real skincare product that i bought for
myself after reading tons of reviews i
think paula's choice is best known for
popularizing chemical exfoliants alpha
hydroxy acids and beta-hydroxy acid are
ingredients that help your dead skin
cells shed more evenly this is something
that naturally happens but sometimes
this natural process
doesn't work as well as we'd like so you
need some exfoliants to come and give it
a bit of a kick along these days it
seems like every brand has a chemical
exfoliant but back then there were about
eight on the market and four of them
were from paula's choice they haven't
changed this formula that much but it
somehow still really stood its own after
more than a decade paula's choice is
just still really dominating when it
comes to salicylic acid formulas this is
still
the best formula i've tried and it's the
one that i keep going back to this is
the skincare product that i've had the
longest relationship with i try a lot of
skincare products and for most product
categories there'll be a few different
options that i end up really enjoying
and using regularly but for salicylic
acid this is the one that's sort of on
its own level for me and i've heard that
a lot of other people also feel the same
way paula's choice has a philosophy
where they always try to include other
supporting ingredients in their products
so this is actually one of their simpler
ones it's got humectants in the base
it's got a bit of green tea as well to
reduce irritation salicylic acid is a
little bit drying on the skin and it can
feel a bit tight while your skin adjusts
to it but i found that following up with
a hydrating tonal or moisturizer really
helps with this i love using this for
keeping my pores clear getting rid of
those little gray dots on your nose and
the pores i put this on with my fingers
and i mostly put it on my t-zone a few
times a week at night i also put it
sometimes a bit on my cheeks as well i
also used to use this in the morning
before but now i kind of just try to
keep my morning routine as simple as
possible this is the liquid version
which comes out very liquidy there's
also a lotion version but i've been so
happy with the liquid version that i've
never really had the urge to try the
lotion a very similar product is the
clear acne body spray this is just
pretty much the same thing but in a
spray form i think they have a few
different ingredients in there as well
but it is mostly that 2 salicylic acid
this is really good for getting my back
the spray sprays even when you put it
upside down which is really handy
i would probably recommend not spraying
your face i feel like exfoliating your
lungs is probably not a good idea the
poreless choice ten percent nicer than
my booster this product is the product
that converted me to niacinamide
niacinamide is a form of vitamin b3 it
is a really great all-around ingredient
and it's gotten really popular lately
niacinamide helps with brightening so it
can reduce the appearance of brown
patches like a lot of other ingredients
but it's also been tested on red
blotchiness and yellow saladness as well
niacinamide also smooths out skin
texture and fine lines and it's one of
the very few ingredients that looks like
it might potentially be able to make
pores look smaller but i think the main
reason people love niacinamide is that
it is one of the few ingredients that's
active but not very irritating at
effective levels if your skin isn't
specifically sensitive to it most of the
other really evidence-backed actives
like retinoids and exfoliating acids
still tend to be a bit irritating even
if your skin's gotten used to it so
niacinamide is like a little working
holiday for your skin so confession time
i wasn't cool enough to like niacinamide
before it became really popular i knew
about all the data backing up its
effectiveness but i tried a couple of
products with niacinamide and i didn't
really see much of a difference so i
gave up pretty quickly but this serum is
the one that actually made a big
difference on my skin and it made me
really probably try out other knives
into my products i've seen other people
say the same thing that this one is just
the one that works the best for them so
i think there is actually quite a lot of
variation with niacinamide formulas even
if they have the same percentage it
could also be the other ingredients in
this so the scoreboard glucoside in that
is a vitamin c derivative and it's one
of my favorites there are a whole bunch
of other supporting ingredients and
antioxidants in this too that also add
to this soothing effect so there's alan
toen and licorice extract paula's choice
really love the antioxidants and this
has a massive list of them the texture
is really watery and light it's a
water-based formula it's very easy to
incorporate into your routine because
it's so light it layers nicely under
everything else you can use it morning
or night i tend to use this every few
nights if my skin is particularly
irritated then sometimes i'll just use
this and nothing else for a few nights
maybe also with a moisturizer there is
also a 20 niacinamide which a lot of
people like if you want to go up even
higher with your niacinamide next up is
the point three percent retinol and two
percent pecucio treatment
this is one of my favorite retinal
products retinol is considered a gold
standard skincare ingredient it's a form
of vitamin a and it's an anti-aging
superstar ingredient back when i first
started on rational i made the mistake
of using a really big blob of the
poreless choice one percent retinol a
few nights in a row and that was a
massive mistake one percent is really
strong i thought my skin could handle it
because i was used to using 20 chemical
exfoliants with no big issues but
retinol is a whole different game i
think the really sneaky thing about
retinoid irritation is that it only
happens about a day and a half after
you've applied it with chemical
exfoliants you can usually tell right
after you've applied it that it's stingy
too much and you need to get it off but
with retinoids the next night your skin
will still usually mostly be fine
so if you're a bit of a chump like me
then you'll end up using even more the
next night because you feel like oh that
didn't actually do much my skin's fine
and then the morning after that you
realize you've just turned your face
into desiccated coconut so after that
intense retinol start my face was red
and peeling and all of those classic
retinol irritation things for like a
whole week plus i caught a cold around
the same time so i was just blowing my
nose a lot and it was just
really bad so that really taught me a
valuable lesson that's what inspired me
to start tretinoin super super slowly
you can see my whole process for that in
my tutorial on starting retinoids so the
one percent is a really good product if
you want something really strong it's
one of the best sellers from paula's
choice but
i think i've thoroughly demonstrated
that i am not responsible enough for
that sort of power even now that my
skin's adjusted to retinoids i find that
sometimes i'll apply too much and then
about 36 hours later i have slightly
peely skin and that can be really
inconvenient if i have a special event
on or if i have to film something it's
really hard to get makeup to sit nicely
on top of peely skin
so i actually like slightly gentler
retinol products this .3 retinol is
really perfect for me because if i'm
really tired and i zone out during my
skincare routine and i apply a little
bit too much it is not a big deal and
this also has other ingredients in there
apart from just the rational so it means
that i can do less steps which is always
great for me and you don't have to think
about layering and ordering and whether
you're using too many things and risking
irritation it just cuts out a whole
bunch of variables and it makes
everything just
so much more straightforward this has
two percent pecutial in it as well
pecutial is an ingredient that comes
from a plant and a lot of people have
been marketing it as a natural
alternative to retinol which
i think
isn't that great the argument is that it
also helps with reducing the appearance
of wrinkles and hyperpigmentation just
like vitamin a
but it isn't a retinoid it doesn't work
the same way as vitamin a and it doesn't
have anywhere near the same level of
evidence as vitamin a but pecucial is
still a pretty promising ingredient and
i really like the way paula's choice
markets this the q-trail is there to
supplement the retinol it's not meant to
replace it this also has peptides and a
whole bunch of skin-soothing ingredients
and antioxidants in that classic paula's
choice formula this is a really nice
lightish lotion i found it gentle and
non-irritating and the base is thick
enough that it works as a moisturizer as
well
on my oily skin at least i just really
love this as a super effective one-step
foolproof product for when i'm really
tired which is
a lot of the time now
next is paula's choice super light daily
wrinkle defense spf 30. this is a tinted
based cosmetic spf in australia but it's
sold as a proper sunscreen in the us and
europe this is the nicest zinc oxide
product i've ever tried i've talked
before about why zinc oxide is so
annoying to use in sunscreens basically
zinc oxide doesn't absorb uv very well
so you need to put a lot of it into a
product to get a decent spf but zinc
oxide is an inorganic mineral which
means it's basically like powdered clay
or ground up rock so if you have 13 zinc
oxide like in this formula that is about
1 7 or 1 8.
so 1 7 or 1 8 this is powdered clay and
the rest is a thickish oily base to try
to keep that powder spread out so it's a
massive challenge to make that feel nice
on your skin and if a sunscreen product
doesn't feel nice then you don't apply
as much which means you don't get as
much sun protection because sps scales
with the amount you apply this is only
spf 30 which isn't that low i feel weird
saying only spf 30 because 10 years ago
spf 30 was heaps but i feel like these
days most of the products on the market
go for spf 50 or 50 plus and that's
quite standard
so because of the i guess slightly lower
than
the most common
spf there's a bit less zinc oxide in
this than you'll usually see so most
sync oxide products with spf 50 or 50
plus will have 20 to 25 which is a
quarter of the product which is
a lot
but for me with zinc oxide sunscreens i
just don't feel like it's worth the high
spf to feel that heaviness on my face
i'm very much a fan of chemical
sunscreens if i want higher spf the
other big issue with zinc oxide is white
cast zinc oxide often looks white on
darker skin and
my skin isn't even that dark but i still
get white cast with a lot of zinc oxide
sunscreens this one is tinted a little
bit to try to hide that white cast and
it works really well on my skin
it did take a minute or two to settle
and when i first put it on i was kind of
worried but yeah this one is pretty
unnoticeable on my face so far no one's
told me anything anyway maybe everyone's
just being really nice
but i did take this photo where i wiped
the sunscreen off half my face and i
couldn't see the difference it's on that
part i have heard that some people with
very dark skin have issues with this but
this is the zinc oxide only product with
the least compromises for me two more
products i wanted to shout out firstly
the c25 super booster this is a vitamin
c product it has ascorbic acid in a
silicone base vitamin c is an
antioxidant that's really great for
brightening skin and evening out your
skin tone ascorbic acid is the form of
vitamin c that has the best evidence but
it's pretty annoying i've talked about
this a whole bunch before it's really
unstable but when it's in a silicone
base like in this product it goes off a
lot slower because the silicone wraps
around the vitamin c and protects it
against oxygen and light and water this
is quite strong which is why i'm putting
it in this separate section
if you don't already use a gentle
ascorbic acid i wouldn't recommend this
i would recommend using the c15 because
this is going to sting the c15 is a more
standard water-based ascorbic acid
product but my skin loves vitamin c and
i take forever to finish products so
this is perfect for me i like to apply
this by mixing it with a different
product first and then applying that
because i do find it a bit strong on its
own and i have this weird thing where i
don't like the feel of silicone skin
care products everyone else says that
silicones are cosmetically elegant and
silky so i am in the minority here i
usually mix a little blob of this with
the two percent bha liquid but you can
mix it in with any serum or moisturizer
paula's choice 10 as a lake acid booster
this is not actually allowed in
australia because azelaic acid is an
over-the-counter drug here but i really
like this because it has a really nice
smooth texture azolic acid products are
sometimes a bit paste like in texture
but this one is really light it feels a
lot more like a regular moisturizer
they've also put licorice and salicylic
acid in here to make a product that's
really good for evening out skin tone
and texture and unclogging pores so
those are my favorite pool of choice
products links to everything are in the
caption thank you so much to paula's
choice for sponsoring this video follow
paula's favorite youtuber on everything
skincare science video should be popping
up here and here if you want to keep
watching